denizens of the last star do you hear
that sound that is the sound of the
inevitable it's only a matter of time
before the last star is consumed by the
void a frightening prospect I know but
you may take some comfort in the fact
that I loathe are bending have ensured
that something of this universe will
survive
and you're trying to stop me because
that something doesn't include you your
spirit is admirable but spirit can save
me from what's coming
nothing can not your surface blades
which are admittedly pretty cool or
whatever
not your stockpiles of munitions not
your what is this magic not your insane
robots or your talents or your or yo yo
yo but theatrics give me a hat vote you
now then where was I
no yes you are
the only choice left you is how you can
die alone you can die clean to your
idiot friends all you can die with the
rest the misbegotten
fill that got a vault into this wretched
system take your pick
but you will die and so back to that
sound
that is the last choking gasp of a dying
cosmos doomed to the dark that is the
sound of the end
you